for silver medal honors we move over to
the city college of new york where
Jeremy Joffe made his film titled the
Bronx balletto mean this dramatic comedy
introduces us to Joey a widowed single
father from the Bronx and he's run bunch
was door to Giselle please welcome the
silver medal award-winning filmmaker
Jeremy Joffe I was pretty cool just
getting an award from gary oldman right
wow I'm I'm just truly overwhelmed right
now I really want to of course like
everybody else I want to thank the
academy they've treated us so well out
here it's it's really been touching and
an honor to be here being being able to
go to the wga and pick some of the
greatest writers minds in the world and
to the ASC and then picking the minds of
some of the greatest cinematographers in
the world has been just the most amazing
experience and I'm so grateful and
appreciative to everybody I would really
love to again thank all the other
filmmakers that have been here I'm
really just touched to be in the same
stage with you guys and to City College
harlem new york yes I've had the
greatest experience there I have to
thank my professors specifically Andre
Krakowski who if it wasn't for him I
would not have been able to use Federico
Castelluccio in this film and Federico
too thanks to him for trusting me
first-time director and I've got some
casting crew out there first of all Gina
bonatti who you also has an amazing
actress playing miss Katerina she's in
the third row right there please stand
up the film would not have been what it
was without her Thank You Gina it was a
great day when she trekked up to Harlem
to audition for us and I've got some
wonderful friends in the audience
Margaret Jimmy Andrew Beatrice and my
friend Dave they're all here and I'm
thinking a lot of people I know but my
cinematographer mr. Chuck Gomez please
stand up
I have to say that in addition to being
a great filmmaker chuck is one of my
best friends and when we lost our one of
our locations that that day when I was
despairing like crazy Chuck came around
to me when I was hiding around the
corner he came around to me and he was
at that point he was just my great
friend and he told he really brought me
back from the depths of despair and we
finished this movie and to my parents
who are out there and my my brother Josh
my sister-in-law Mabel and my amazing
choreographer Emily Joffe my sister who
was there every day on the set even when
she wasn't choreographing she was there
supporting me I definitely believe in
nepotism and i just also would really
love to thank my my wonderful wonderful
soul mate april who's back home and
they're definitely should be award for
those who have been supporting us behind
the scenes she actually gave birth on
tuesday and my daughter Jillian Shay is
back home I was able to spend the night
in the hospital with her and I was
getting cold feet about coming here and
April says if you don't go I'm going to
kick your ass so I came so thank you so
much
you